YOUNG MAN OUTSIDE THE LANE.
>> Joel: SO ANOTHER SECOND
CHANCE OPPORTUNITY.
BLOCKED AWAY BY UPSETS ME?
THIS IS WHY I TALK ABOUT GUYS
BEING UNFAIRLY OFFICIATING.
IF IT'S ZION, HE DOESN'T GET
THAT CALL.
I'M NOT SAYING IF IT'S FOUL OR
NOT A FOUL, WHAT I'M SAYING
IS -- MAN, I'M SORRY.
I'M STILL KINDTHREE-BALL GOING
COBY WHITE.
COBY WHITE COMES IN.
HE'S AT LEAST TWOAT HE'S DONE O
SEVEN, EIGHT GAMES.
PRETTY AMAZING.
FIVE-SECOND DIFFERENCE HERE IN
THE END OF THE HALF.
NOW ON A SWITCH, MARSHALL ON
CURRY.
AND WITH THE FLOATER THAT IS NO
GOOD.
MARSHALL, FOUR
COMING UP, TOYOTA "SPORTSCENTER"
HALFTIME, SCOTT VAN PELT WILL
LOOK AT THE  OF 18.
>> IT HAS BEEN AN EMPTY NIGHT.
DORT.
TRYING TO BREAK DOWN THAT
PELICANS DEFENSE.
MALEDON.
IT IS, OH, WHAT AN WHICH THREW U
OFF A LITTLE BIT.
AND THEN THE TRAJECTORY OF THE
BALL, YOU'RE THINKING THERE'S NO
WA THAT'S THE BEAUTY OF
JAXSON HAYES, LONG, LEAN, GREAT
SPEED, EXCELLENT THREAT
VERTICALLY AT THE RIM.
>> Ryan: NICE FIND. IN THE PAIND
A LITTLE BIT OF FRUSTRATION FROM
TOM THIBODEAU G